was it a mistake for the united states
to invade afghanistan in 2001 20 years
ago
yes
as simple as yes why was it a mistake
i'm historian so i say this with you
know some humility about what we can
though i think you know i'd still like
to know much more about what was going
on in the white house you know in the
hours days weeks you know after 9 11 but
i think
the george w bush administration acted
in a state of panic and i think they
wanted to show kind of toughness they
wanted to show
some kind of resolve you know this was a
horrific act
that played out you know on everyone's
television screens and i think it was
really uh
fundamentally a crisis of legitimacy
within the white house than level offs
and i think they felt like they had to
do
something and something dramatic
i think they didn't really think through
you know who they were fighting you know
who the enemy was
what this geography had to do with 911 i
think looking back at it i mean some of
us not say i was you know clairvoyant or
could see in the future but i think many
of us were
from that morning skeptical about the
connections that people were drawing
between afghanistan as a state
as a place and the actions of al qaeda
in washington and
new york and pennsylvania
so as you watch the events of 9 11
the things that
our leaders were saying in the in the
minutes hours
days weeks that followed maybe you can
give a little bit of a timeline
of what was being said when was the
actual invasion of afghanistan and also
what were your feelings in the minutes
weeks
after 9 11. i was in dc i was you know
on the way to american university uh
hearing on npr
what happened
and i thought of the
american university logo which is red
white and blue it's an eagle and i
thought you know washington is under
attack and symbols of american power are
under attack
and so um yeah i was quite concerned and
at the time lived you know just a few
miles from the capitol
and so um you know i i felt it you know
it was it was real so i appreciate the
yeah the sense of anxiety and fear and
panic and for
two three years later in dc we were
constantly getting
reports you know mostly rumors and
unconfirmed about all kinds of attacks
before the city so i definitely
um appreciate the sense of being under
assault but in watching television
including russian television that day
because i just
just installed a satellite thing so i
was trying to watch world news and get
different points of view and
that was quite useful to have an
alternative you know set of eyes in
russian yeah in russian yeah okay so
your russians is uh is good enough to
understand uh russian television the
news yeah the news and the visuals that
were coming that were not shown on
american television
i don't know how they had it but they
had they were not filtering anything
in the way that the major networks and
cable televisions were doing here so it
was
a very unvarnished view of the violence
of the moment you know new york city of
people diving from the towers or being
just you know it was really
they didn't hold back on that which was
quite you know fascinating i think much
of the world saw much more than actually
the american public saw
but to your question you know amid that
feeling of imminent doom
i watch commentators start to talk about
al qaeda and then talk about afghanistan
and
one of the experts was um was barnett
rubin um he was at nyu he's a you know
kind of long
very learned um afghanistan hand
and he's brought on peter jennings on
abc news to
to kind of lay this out for everyone um
and i thought you know he did a fine job
but i think it it was formative in
cementing the view that
somehow al-qaeda was synonymous with
this space afghanistan
and i think
again
i was an al-qaeda expert then and i'm
not now
but i think my immediate thought went to
war
and because my background had been with
at that point mostly afghans who had
been displaced from decades of war
whom i encountered in uzbekistan who
were refugees and so on
i thought immediately my mind went to
the suffering
of afghan people that this war was going
to
sweep
sweep up of course the the defenseless
people who have nothing to do with these
politics so we should give maybe a
little bit of context yeah you can speak
too yeah
so assume nobody's an expert in anything
yeah so let's just say
you're you and i are not experts in
anything right what
as a historian were you studying at the
time and thinking about see
uh is it is it the full global history
of afghanistan is it the region
were you thinking about
the
hadin and al-qaeda and taliban were you
thinking about the soviet union
the proxy war through afghanistan were
you thinking about iraq and oil like
what what's the full space of things in
your heart in your mind at the time i
mean just at the moment of course it was
you know there's the sense of
you know the suffering and the tragedy
of the moment of you know what the death
that was i think i was preoccupied by
by the violence at the moment
um but as the conversation turned to
afghanistan as a kind of theater to
somehow respond to this moment i think
immediately what came to mind was that
little i knew about al-qaeda the times
said that the geography was was
inaccurate that this was a global
network a global threat that this is a
kind of you know
a movement that went beyond borders and
i think that
it felt early on that
afghanistan was going to be used as a
scapegoat and this intellectually at the
time you know i was teaching at american
university my courses
you know touched on ranger subjects but
i was trying to complete a book on um
islam in the russian empire actually
but in doing that research which took me
across russia and central asia purely by
accident i had developed an interest in
afghanistan because
uh just again a series of coincidences
i found myself in tashkent the capital
of like town without housing
through an american friend who was like
the king of the market in tashkent he
knew everyone he run into some afghan
merchants there
they found out i didn't have a place to
live
i didn't know where afghanistan was
honestly this was 1997. i had a big idea
it was next door well you lived in
uzbekistan yeah in tashkent doing doing
distinction research yeah because it was
you know hub of the russian empire in
central asia yeah so just by accident
with these young afghans who took me in
as roommates
and that i think that the sense of that
community
shaped my idea of what afghanistan is it
was my
first exposure to them they're part of a
trading diaspora they brought
they had brought matches from riga
latvia
they somehow brought um
flour and some agricultural products
from from egypt and they were sitting in
enclosed containers in tashkent waiting
for
these pakistani state to permit them to
trade
so these guys are mostly hanging out
during the day they'll get dressed up
they put on suits and ties like you're
wearing they'd polish their shoes and
they would sit around offices
drink tea
pistachios
then they feast at lunch
and then at night we would go out so
part of my research because i also had a
bottleneck in my research i was going to
the state archives in tashken
and because of the state of uzbekistan
you know that was a very kind of
suspicious thing to do so it took a
while to get in so i had downtime in
touch can just like these guys so i got
to know them pretty well and it was
really just a
an accidental kind of thing but
grew quite close to them and i developed
an appreciation of um
which now i think again thinking of the
seeds of all this um these people had
already lived
young guys you know in their 20s they'd
already lived in 67 countries
they all spoke half a dozen languages
one of my best friends there had been a
um a kickboxer
and breakdancer trained in tehran his
father was a theater person in
afghanistan
he told stories of escaping death in
afghanistan during the civil war
going to this bakatan escaping death
there
and these were very you know real
stories can you also just briefly
mention yeah
geographically speaking yes afghanistan
uzbekistan tajikistan you mentioned iran
right what uh who are the neighbors of
all this what are we supposed to be
thinking about for people
i i was always terrible at geography and
spatial information so can you lay it
out yeah i'm sure sure so tashkent you
know is a is the capital of uzbekistan
it was um
a hub of russian imperial power in the
19th century the russians take the city
from a local
kind of muslim dynasty in 1865
it becomes the city the kind of hub of
um soviet power in central asia after
1917
it becomes the
center of
the soviet republic of uzbekistan
which becomes independent finally in
1991 when the soviet union collapses so
these are all like these uh republics
are the fingertips of soviet power in
central asia that's right
and
they've been independent since 1991 but
they have struggled to
disentangle themselves from moscow from
one another
and now they face very serious pressure
from china
to form a kind of periphery of
you know the great machine that is the
chinese economy and its
ambitions to stretch across asia
um for afghanistan where my roommates my
friends hailed from um
yeah afghanistan had fallen
into
civil war in the late 1970s
when leftists tried to cease power there
in 1978
the soviet union then extended from
uzbekistan you know crossing the border
with its forces in 1979 to try to shore
up this leftist government that had
ceased power in 1978
um and so
for central asians in the wider region
you know their their fate had for some
decades been tied to afghanistan in a
variety of ways but it became much more
connected in 1980s when the soviet red
army occupied afghanistan for 10 years
and here i refer your listeners and
viewers to um rainbow three as the guide
to
the historically accurate historically
accurate the bible
the bible of african history and rainbow
three yeah as a fantastic um window onto
the american view the war right but for
us afghans you know they're people who
fought against the soviet army
um but of a certain generation
the guys i knew
you know their mission was to survive
and so they fled in waves you know by
the millions to pakistan
to iran some went north into south
central asia later in the 1990s
and some were displaced across the
planet so california where we're sitting
today has a large community that came
in the 80s and 90s
in the east bay
you